well
wow
that's cherry
jerry
cherry oh where'd you girl where are you
from originally uh forward speakers fort
worth texas
and what was your childhood like you had
both mom and dad i had mom and dad my
there was sexual abuse mental abuse and
physical abuse is that right
but
what would you describe your childhood
like i mean uh
if i could describe it i said it wasn't
good because i was put out of the house
at the age of 12. and mentioned it
you were put out of 12 for what i
emancipated my mother or you were
emancipated i had a first grandchild and
she ignored him and didn't exit
and then i talked with my aunts further
down the line and they told me why that
my mom had an affair
and i'm the offspring and don't think i
was his but she didn't never tell her oh
i see
so i reminded her of that every day
that's why she got rid of me what kind
of kid were you in high school
huh i was an athletic
auxiliary
a mathematician is that right
you finished high school
no i i was 61 grades for hitting the
principal
hitting the principal
what made you hit the principal who
walked in the bathroom when my
girlfriend
said she was moving look
said she was not miserable that's right
i'm sorry he walked in away bathroom to
see she was smoking
i walked in behind and said what are you
doing trying to get a free show
and he said no i am too late
i gotta hide timber i learned to control
it
i'm 55 now man you're 55.
i've been on the street since i was 12.
i don't know i've been married five
times four one in one minute
so you've been uh transgender i've been
transgender since birth
i didn't know until i was six
but you were marrying women yeah i
wasn't trying that out and it didn't
feel right but i got too clear about two
beautiful women
but my creative zone and knowledge many
different ways i made my transformation
yeah and you've been living here on skid
row for how long
um obviously right now i've been
uh what it's called bridge housing i got
an apartment coming up right now it
should be this way sometime i'm going to
get my opponent see if it came in
but
all my life i've been learning since i
was 12 on and off of my sid rosenberger
six yeah you've been in california for
how long uh this time i've been back for
three years three years
and looking back at your life i mean do
you have any regrets
i have a couple but
not serious because
i want to know what i know now
if i didn't get taught that lesson
yeah i've heard that a lot and people
just know school hard knocks is a great
school
but sometimes we get really dangerous
do you have friends today
you want do you have friends today my
friend
he's walking me through the doctor's
hospital and getting my phone
and we're going to joshua house to save
their head business
are you happier as a trans
i'm a more bad person because i love
myself and i love god
when i was male i couldn't love myself
i hated myself yeah i hated who i was i
hated where i tried to be
then you feel like you were born this
way is that something
you were molested as a child or anything
like that
i was molested from
i swear 39
did that church when my mom put me out
at 12.
i stayed in church from 12 to 18
and it was nothing but six or eight
every night
nothing but what sexual youth
where at the end of the church at the
church it was the american orthodox type
of church holy city in america that's a
hell of a challenge
bishop personal assistant and lover
this is in texas no this was right here
in california i'm like california i
really grew up until i was 21. wow
i've been in sixth grade business all my
life yeah
i've been immune to business all my life
i'm born and raised on
carnegie
and
i live on the streets right here in
california and several other states so
you'll travel around the u.s
i did
yeah
when you're a kearney yeah tell me about
the carnie life there's drugs involved
it's a whole new world after i can't
speak of it because they're fluent
secrecy is that right
i'm the truth aren't you i ain't going
to sleep in my mind
but yeah that's a drug well after but
i have a different way of life a
different rule you know homeless right
now homeless won't work out there you
might bomb somebody out there and get
your ass whoop and sit down in the room
what drugs have you played around with
in your life i've been on math
i started out with heroin cocaine
you don't speak balls until i'm 21 for
12.1
that's the way i cope with the stress
and what i had to do
then i moved to
missouri
met my wife got married i quit
everything made it happen
but i wasn't happy
i felt like something was wrong
and i'll try to find her she's gonna
understand by the way we're still
married 31 years or so oh you're still
married yeah and we don't believe in
divorce
but she sounded like married to someone
else
do you self contact with your kids uh i
try to stay in contact with him on the
internet my son's in prison in
california and when i graduated after
him when he was three
and one in arkansas i hadn't seen since
he was six
so i stayed on the internet and keep up
with them
but they want to acknowledge me since i
pulled the train out nine years ago
so back to the carny thing the the the
kearney code of not of secrecy is is for
what purpose because everyone has some
dark secrets yeah
remember the whole new life out there
i'll put in that one yeah
interesting
and you're the today you're living where
you're on the street um not on the
streets i'm in shelter in belle
california
that's what we're just saying brown it's
called satellites you know i'm in that
bell
but i ain't there that long that's why
i'm trying to get my phone to sit my
house and come through yeah because i
already had having set up i was just
waiting for the inspection
and then i can move in and the the sex
work that you do tell me about that i
don't do that anymore you don't know i'm
retired
i'm not
getting all that when you were doing it
tell me about that
i'm gonna go mine
had a lifetime
and it was in eight different states
i made a living on them yeah the jasmine
i got anything so far i said no because
i don't
they almost killed me
streets almost feeling like i said i've
been shot twice because i'm trying to
i've been stabbed four times yeah so i
robbed over 19 times i've been eight
hate crimes yeah transgender women get a
lot of hate crimes i think
that's why i don't walk alone i walk
with somebody and he actually like one
walk with me and i said yeah you can
walk with me
he's a good friend but you're a big
woman you're tall mm-hmm how tall are
you i'm two three six three yeah you
probably take care of yourself
i try to
i mean i don't wanna live in five
because they're the same staffers out
there i mean then stop since i was
twelve when i grew up on the street and
drive on
and follow me through every state
anything crap right now they're still
getting stalking me i don't know who it
is i can't tell you but every time i see
them i walk into the car and see what
they're doing and they'll drive off
because they don't want to talk
now i noticed the armenians
the cocktail and all these other games
out here let's do it but ever since this
cell phone come along
people look up look at me actually know
me forever but
how the only way i configured his own
trouble
do you feel like you were loved when you
were a child
was i loved yeah
no love in the house love was sex in
that house
i learned what my love was through the
bible studying it for six years and
going past it and becoming theologians
and all that and i spread the word every
day with everybody give unconditional
love you'll see the world in a different
way
but if you put conditions on it you
can't see it the way i see it
because
money
rules everything out here
and corporate america owns that money so
who runs america corporate america
yes i think that's the ones that stuff
and sometimes because i figured out
their little tricks
because they suck me so much and they're
twisting my mind
every time i see him i don't get fearful
anymore because for years i just fear
i turn that fear into anger and turn it
back on
but what emotions do do you go through
do you get depressed or angry or
i know people personally more i mean
like i said i found god i'm not alone
i do get scared
like i did last night when the hospital
approximately dying is that what you're
most afraid of
died i was children i'm playing and they
told me that when my kidneys shutting
down as long as my heart
i'm a miracle if they walk in today
and basically doctors come in and say
their body shuts down nothing new
get back on the street
go home and back safely yeah make it
really much larger
but they tried to play around playing
around with it and told me until i said
man come on i feel like i'm dying just
tell me i'm dying
to get over it
and that's when i can come out and try
to get the body stuck to me if you were
to die
if you were to die sometime soon would
you feel like you lived the life you
wanted to
no because i'm still trying to get
through my full transformation
i'm trying to transform into a full
woman and i was supposed to be mourning
oh so you're looking to have some
surgeries too yes i've already gotten
approved and everything and we're trying
to head for this month obviously
my physical feminization stuff but i
don't know if they'll do it now because
of the issue of the hospital
so my heart's slowly going yeah
but you're still driven to have have
certain body parts remove my son
i'm gonna fight i ain't getting up
i'll fight for my last breath
what would you say is the most important
thing you've learned in your in your 55
years
listen to god
you know if you don't think you're here
he's talking to your heart
borrow your heart and knock your head
because it hits the devil
and that's in my eyes
every time i get up here i get any
problem
every time i listen to my heart
everything starts happening
all right sherry thank you so much for
sharing your story
i wish you the best of luck with your
health and your surgeries thank you
thank you very much
you